one of the most impressive pieces of
next generation technology
is the playstation 5's dual sense
controller it's decked out with all
sorts of tech bells and whistles that
can augment gameplay
when it's fully utilized the dual sense
is maybe the most exciting thing about
the ps5 and the thing that's most likely
to alter the way we experience games
you get the best sense of what the dual
sense can do with astro's playroom
the 3d platformer that comes bundled
with the ps5
astros playroom goes wild in showing off
the controller's features
it places a big emphasis on haptic
feedback the tactile sensations created
by the controller's vibrations and
rumbles
it also does a lot with the controller's
adaptive triggers and utilizes its touch
pad
internal gyroscope and built-in
microphone all of those elements
work to transform astro from a fairly
standard platformer
into something much more interesting
let's start with the haptics
the dual sense features enhanced
rumbling that doesn't just shake the
whole controller but can pinpoint
sensations in different places on the
gamepad
pretty much everything you do in astros
playroom produces some haptic feedback
from punching enemies to just walking
across surfaces when astro's robotic
metal feet hit a metal surface you feel
the feedback with every step
alternating on different sides of the
controller skating across
ice produces a thinner vibration across
a larger area to give the sense of
gliding
and when it rains you get random
vibrations at points all over the
controller
with all that extra feedback you really
feel a lot closer to astros actions
even though you're just holding a
controller the haptics help you feel
what's going on in the game
while you see it next we've got the
adaptive triggers
the triggers on the dual sense can
change their tension depending on the
situation to make using them feel more
realistic
so when astro picks up a bow and arrow
the trigger tension increases to mirror
the sensation of straining to pull back
on the string
it's a little touch that again makes
what you're doing with the controller
match what you're seeing on screen a
little more closely the dual sense also
includes some older features from past
playstation controllers
there's the big touchpad which you'll
use in astro by swiping your finger
across it to roll a ball
there's the gyroscope which lets you
tilt and move the dual sense to control
certain things
and there's the microphone and speaker
which make talking to your party a
little easier
the speaker is pretty great when used
with the haptics since the small
sounds of walking on metal or sand help
your brain make sense of what you're
feeling with the controller
the old controller features combined
with the new ones to create some fresh
experiences
astros playroom shows off just how cool
the dual sense can be
and it is pretty cool
if there's a drawback though it's that
so many of the features
might not get broad use in games
particularly those games that are
released
on multiple platforms take spider-man
miles morales as an example
like astro it's a first-party ps5 launch
game and it has some cool dual sense
specific features
the adaptive triggers set different
tensions for your webs as you swing
around new york or yank weapons out of
the hands of enemies
certain moments like when miles rides
the subway push the haptics in
interesting ways with the controller
simulating the field the tracks beneath
his feet
but spider-man definitely doesn't have
the dedication to the dual sense
that astro does which could be a result
of the fact that it's also coming out on
ps4
developer insomniac games has done some
things with the controller but those
things
don't really change the spider-man
experience sony has had technologically
impressive devices in the past that have
offered new opportunities for gameplay
but they've
often gone under-used by developers for
instance not many games really embraced
the dualshock 4's touch pad
light bar and gyroscope last generation
the playstation vita handheld sported a
touchpad
a touchscreen a camera and a microphone
all of those elements offered cool ways
to change gameplay but only a handful of
sony-backed games
really use them like astra's playroom
with the dual sense sony developer media
molecule released tearaway to show off
all the features of both the vita and
the dualshock 4 but that game didn't
inspire a wave of novel uses for the
hardware from
other developers as a piece of next-gen
technology
the dual sense comes with a lot of
possibilities the features it brings to
the table have the potential to offer
new avenues for gameplay and new ways
for us to connect with games
but that will only happen if developers
embrace the hardware
and there really hasn't been a great
track record of that over the last two
generations
if you're picking up a ps5 you should
play astros playroom and see what some
of this next gen tech is capable of
delivering
and hopefully we'll see more developers
inspired to adopt the dual senses
features as we get into the ps5
generation
you